jean luc serre bonjour bonjour les giec
nous dit manger moins de viande mais bon
tout cela pour qui la viande fait partie
prenante de leur alimentation quotidien
par où commencer
on commence on peut commencer par
arrêter de manger un animal comme le
porc moi personnellement j'ai arrêté de
manger du porc pour commencer où on peut
commencer par un jour par semaine deux
jours par semaine ou même pourquoi pas
un report de des gens qui mangent de la
viande rouge par jour c'est important
mais c'est comme ça pourquoi pas
commencer par un repos peut-être le
lundi car les lundis sans viande
commencé par intégrer plus de légumes
dans notre alimentation est autrement
dit la viande va se se faire plus rares
plus qu'on va inclure de protéines
végétales
quand vous vous dites que vous avez
commencé avec la part et quand on
regarde la pollution qu'elles créent les
différentes productions de viande
d'élevage de viande chaque viande
il n'y a pas une équivalence à ce que
par exemple le boeuf c'est ce qui
profite à vendre je suis très
énergivores pour produire un quart de
livre de boeuf haché on a besoin de 3000
hebdo c'est comme si on prenait une
douche de deux mois c'est
extraordinairement énergivores leboeuf
pour produire un kilogramme de boeuf on
a besoin de dix kilos de protéines
végétales donc le buzz c'est
définitivement la viande qu'il faut
couper en premier lieu quand on veut
faire une expérience sur l'environnement
et là la grande question pour ceux qui
vont commencer à couper
la consommation de viande c'est pourquoi
on remplace le tour fut le bras meurtris
le fameux fut le préféré des familles
d'espoir dans mais tottenham très
mauvaise réputation mais c'est quelque
chose trop savoir quoi faire avec
pour mettre une bonne sauf moi je dis
toujours aux gens s'ils mettent une
dispute futile de maïs sur le tofu qui
peut l'en accusent faites revenir dans
l'huile comme ça on va changer les
textes sont juste parce que c'est
souvent détection qu'on impose un petit
peu caoutchouteux l'unesco mais en
remplaçant le poulet par le tofu par
exemple dans un corps fut général tao ou
la sauce à spaghetti m'étais dit que fut
hachée dans votre sauce à spaghetti
garantie devrait pas différence avec le
buzz
on parle beaucoup de te fume il ya
d'autres choses que quand même il y en a
qui voudront peut-être s'attaquer au
tofu qui demandent peuvent être une
préparation un peu différent parce qu'on
va se dire là là bas ça vaut pas grand
chose mais qu'est ce que donne des
légumineuses
c'est tellement pêcheurs des pois
chiches votre préparation on ouvre la
boîte de conserve on y goûte enfin bon
carry on fait de l'humour saison les
pois chiches c'est plein de fibres
parce que les gens souvent tendance à
avoir peur de manquer trois tsb si je
mange pas de viande je manquais de
protéines dans notre société on se croit
malade il manque de protéines on peut
manquer de fibres moment cuatro tandis
que dans les pois chiches dans les
légumineuses comme dans les lentilles ya
beaucoup de fibres au président a clos
son intérêt de ma passion on entend
souvent dire que manger plus vegan ça
coûte plus cher ça goûte - sa demande
vraiment
d'abord parce que c'est vrai ça coûte si
cher vous pensez que ça coûte plus cher
à manger vegas j'avais mon sens vous
avez acheté des crevettes parce que des
pois chiche qu'on va revenir là dessus
c'est pratiquement 4 5 ou d'une pièce et
25 une canne en entre deux portions
facilement que ça c'est des pois chiches
en concert sont facturés aux
légumineuses soi même ça devient
compliqué mais je pensais qu ainsi par
portion avec moi j'ai jamais eu autant
de diversité dans mon alimentation que
depuis que suivait guen j'ai jamais ça
moi j'aime aussi très peu cher pour moi
je donc fausses croyances
cependant la question que ça goûte moins
ça demande quand même une façons
d'apprêter différemment c'est comme
apprendre un nouveau langage faut pas
hésiter à aller se tourner vers les
cuisines du monde de cuisine
thaïlandaise entre autres parce que je
voyage en thaïlande fut d'abord la
viande c'est presque demain c'est à dire
que on un carry on va ajouter d'avion ou
du cocu ou découvert vie si on n'a pas
bien beau mais dû stopper ça va coûter
la même chaussée les épices qui font
agresser alors oui pour la viande de
gibier également on gaspille énormément
que le tiers de ce qui est produit à
l'échelle mondiale et jeté à la poubelle
commun on peut dans nos gestes au
quotidien nous à la maison gaspillé mois
il faut commencer par cuisine quand on
cuisine
moi je suis chef devenu une formation
que dans un restaurant si on a des
champignons pour autour une recette pour
dépasser les champignons parce qu'on
jette à rien la restauration sinon on
jette les profits c'est que la maison
comprendre la même attitude pour avoir
un bon livre de recettes
au lieu de jeter des légumes
on les cuisine de toute façon le tofu
consomment beaucoup plus longtemps que
les produits carnés les légumes ça se
conserve plus longtemps que les footeux
les fruits demain c'est quand on a une
alimentation végétale rouge est
automatiquement moins de produits parce
que vous devez beaucoup plus longue
'cela fait 13 ans 8 matchs et riche ce
que le giec vient de sortir comme
conclusion ça donne des munitions à ceux
qui ont créé en fait du côté de santé
canada le nouveau guide alimentaire
canadien vos espoirs que la jeune
génération en fait plus besoin de
s'adapter en fait parce que ce serait
déjà fait d'un très jeune conscientisés
à manger davantage de vigueur des jeunes
sont rendus les climato-sceptiques rayon
pas 2 1 c'est baby boomers pour la
plupart des gens qui croient pas au
réchauffement climatique les jeunes n'y
croient plus autant que moi ma
génération on avait peur de la guerre
froide des choses comme ça mais demain
des gens ont vraiment par les jeunes du
climat puis avec raison
j'attends ce point 5 % les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sont causés par
l'élevage industriel
c'est plus que tous les moyens de
transport réunissent avant d'acheter une
tesla vous devez acheter du tofu ça
coûte beaucoup moins cher
alors on change nos habitudes c'est
normal que ça peut se faire un peu peur
au début ça fait toujours pas parce que
c'est c'est pas familier mais moi je dis
toujours aux gens la révision ne jamais
convaincu personne d'arrêter de manger
de la viande pour y aller faut prêcher
par la fourchette faut y aller avec des
des tout conviviale généreux
les recettes qu'on connaît notre
spaghetti notre portée chinois pour
organiser nos recettes notre famille
d'embarquer ses sorties il va
tranquillement pour ce soit un
changement durable non voilà une mode
qui durera quelques semaines la
fiduciaire merci beaucoup
le point minimes 1